SECOND START HERE TONIGHT FOR
THE MINNESOTA THEM.
HE TOUGH GRIND
FOR THIS GROUP ON FLYERS HAD ORL
LEADS IN WHAT HAVE SOME
>> KAPRIZOV BACK INTO HIS OWN
ZONE.
THE LOOSE PUP PICKED UP BY
AND BRANDON DUHUH STREAK.
>> SENDING IT ACROSS, WITH A
SAVE, THE R R
[CHEERS] PUTS IT RIGHT
SCORES.>> ERIKSSON-EK AND SIX-GG
STREAK, PITTSBURGH COMING ON
THURSDAY NIGHT. SPURGEON.
NOW HE CONTROLS IT.
HE PENALTY KILL UP.
CHANCE ARE
AT FULL STRENGTH.
THEY CENTER IT.BY MINNESOTA GETD
CHANGE.
>> A SMART AND MATURE CHANGE
THEISTATE OFDED SHOT, PUTTING IT
RIGHT
[APPLAUSE]
>> WOW, WHATHISE RECORD,
>> OUTFRONT, MARC-ANDRE OFF.
MI.
>> WE CALL T PENALTY
KEEPING THE LEAD AT THREE AND
NOW MINNESOTA WILL BE A MAN UP